what were you in pee wee's play house by
the way i was duke uh no not the
playhouse i was in uh
peewee's big top was that one of your
first acting jobs that was my first
first acting job that's a pretty big
deal to me i bet you
and i was duke the dog face boy man you
auditioned for pee wee herman himself
yes okay did you get to know pee wee
when you worked out i did i did you when
you auditioned for pee wee's uh play out
this is in the early days of your career
how old were you back there i was 20 19
20 20. 20 years old and you walk in and
there's a lot of people auditioning how
do you land a job like that how do you
make yourself special well i actually
auditioned for the tv show
right and i didn't get this the job and
then when the movie was happening
i was called in does that destroy you
when you know inside your heart you're a
good actor
and you go and audition for some
television show and you don't get it
how do you keep your show was a classic
it is a classic it is i love peewee yeah
i love the movie show oh is it classic
but then well it's even worse to get
turned down from something you really
want to be a part of right well you know
i yeah exactly how did you deal with the
rejection and you go god damn i can't
get the job on peewee's playhouse come
on no no you just go like one ear out
the other is that true yeah yeah because
it's an actor you have your confidence
like it's like baseball you know yeah
how did you get that though how do i
mean you know most people like crumble
up and die every time i would that's why
i the auditions were leveled yeah how
did you have that at 19. i don't know
you know it's like you just do it it's
exciting to do an audition you know
you're going in and it's you know you
get
you're not used to it
so the first real acting job you had was
in a movie with peewee isn't that weird
that you get chocolate conditioning for
the wolf man yeah i mean is it weird
that you were chosen to be a dog face
boy and now you're a wolf man right so
you kind of have that wolf vibe but the
difference is
i picked this one the other one they
picked me